fait pas convaincu mais je pense que je
peux dire de la crédibilité scientifique
de chela pour convaincre les gens de se
faire vacciner je pense que le plus
important c'est d'expliquer le rationnel
de la vaccination c'est que le bénéfice
est bien supérieur aux risques de la
vaccination particulier chez en tout 55
ans et dont je pense que c'est ça que
les gens doivent comprendre et après
tout l'initiative est bonne si ça peut
convaincre une certaine frange de la
population dès qu'ils croient plus à
sheila cas des médecins ou des
scientifiques pourquoi pas mais de mon
côté je pense que ce n'est pas ça qui me
convient et je pense que c'est une bonne
idée pourquoi pas si ça fonctionne il
faut que chacun est à sa place il faut
déjà que la communication pour le vaccin
était meilleur au départ et qu'on soit
sûr de l'efficacité de ces vaccins ce
n'est pas forcément le cas même pour le
kaiser
voilà donc je sais pas trop quelle
solution à voir mais
[Musique]
bon je sais pas c'est pas si c'est une
bonne solution pour les people si ça
permet de se vacciner pourquoi pas après
celle à ou quelqu'un d'autre
oui voilà si vraiment les gens ça les
pousse parce que c'est vrai est ce que
simplement voir une personnalité ça ça
permet d'envisager le vaccin
différemment notamment astrazeneca je
suis pas trop sûr à voir quoi
encore une fois si les gens préfèrent
croire sheila et pense que c'est elle
qui sait quel est le bénéfice risque
pour ce vaccin je pense que autant
tenter notre chance et puis essayer de
convaincre les gens je pense que tout ce
qui peut convaincre les gens est bon moi
de mon côté c'est comme je pense que je
croirais pas celle à plus que les
médecins ou les scientifiques mais je
suis ouvert à toute proposition je pense
qu'il faut se faire vacciner pour
essayer d'arrêter cette épidémie les
gens en ont assez de conscience ont
eux-mêmes pour savoir il n'y a pas
besoin d'avoir des gens du show-biz ou
qui que ce soit qui vous dit votre voilà
c'est une arme supplémentaire on va dire
un élément supplémentaire pour essayer
de convaincre des gens qui ne seraient
pas très informé
pourquoi pas mais je doute de
l'efficacité d'une telle mesure
tous les moyens sont bons pour pour
inciter les gens à se faire vacciner
après c'est vrai que l'astra zeneca en
ce moment il ya une controverse par
rapport à tout ce qui est en effet
indésirable donc
voilà il faut aussi regarder en
parallèle ce qui se dit au niveau de
l'actualité au niveau des
recommandations et mais la vaccination
voilà que ce soit l'as traces des cas ou
fighter ou autre je pense que voilà il
faut sensibiliser tout le monde par tous
les moyens
bon après ce qui est farfelu ce serait
de savoir réellement l'astra zeneca ce
qu'il en est de ce vaccin
particulièrement après s'il ne serait
utilisé une personnalité pour l'ensemble
des vaccins
je pense que la vaccination mais ça peut
être une bonne chose
chaque professionnel ses compétences
donc sont patchés la icaunaise branche
grand chose en termes de vaccination et
c'est donc juste pour ça je pense qu'un
médecin devrait être plus est apte à
répondre plutôt que qu'un people en fait